hey folks is Josh Tony rich farmer
welcome to the farm blog today it is
what I like to call Golden Hour the Sun
is setting the trees are beautiful
everything looks wonderful we've got a
few things we've got to tackle today
we've got to go up and check on the
goats I'm gonna show you some new gear
that we got for the Gator we're gonna
have a little bit of an unboxing I've
got a big shipment in from Amazon today
and about a bunch of goodies to put on
the Gator to make things a little bit
easier to haul around the farm and the
last thing we're gonna do my lawn mower
seems to constantly have a flat tire so
today we're going to address that
problem I've got some new inner tubes
for the front wheels on my zero turn
mower we'll take the tire off the rim
slap those new tubes in there come on
along I'll have a little bit of fun
today first we're going to go check on
the goats get a little bit of work done
all right
[Music]
so first thing we're gonna do is head up
to the goat pin where I'm gonna need
this pitchfork I'll show you why I need
the pitchfork I've got an issue and
we're gonna solve this issue probably in
one of the next few vlogs and I'll take
you up there and I'll show you what the
biggest issue is it's easier if I can
show you let's go have some play that's
one thing about golden our golden hour
doesn't last very long and the grass is
really coming in nice the Sun it's
beautiful man look at that
this is all the new ground the new grass
that we sowed this year it's coming in
nice and thick we saw this last
September and this is some of the debris
that's fallen from the windstorm so over
the past two days here we've had bad bad
winds the East Coast is experiencing
what they call a nor Easter and that's
pushing a lot of wind a lot of cold wind
off the coast right to us and it's
knocking trees down so we had a fire
yesterday my neighbor called me up he
said hey man you know your fields on
fire I said what let's feed the goats so
here's the goat feed and here's the
goats I am getting ready to start
relocating the goats in this area right
here and basically we're going to move
them from plot to plot to plot all
throughout this field hay goatees so
let's talk to you a little bit about the
problem that I'm having up at the goat
pen I put round bales in the goat pin
for the goats to eat and this is what
happens to them they get climbed all
over and they eventually just get kind
of spread out there all over the field
the pasture here and they bind up the
fence with it also so this is an
electric poultry net and that's what
keeps the goats in but it doesn't work
if it looks like this let me show you
the goats have spread out the hay all
the way up against the fence right in
here all the way down to here so we've
got to get that off I've got to get that
under control and we've got to find a
better way to feed our goats hey they're
just wasting hay they're just wasting it
they're spreading it out on the ground
which is good for the ground that's okay
but they're wasting hay and I'm gonna
take you over here and I'll show you
what my idea is this is an old tobacco
trailer used to haul tobacco I bought it
from a guy a few years back and I built
a mobile chicken coop a egg mobile out
of this thing
well I've built the egg mobile a little
bit too top-heavy and it nearly turned
me and the Gator over so we had to
rethink what we were doing and we took
off the chicken coop and reuse the
materials when we built our chicken coop
down by the garden so my thought is to
convert this to the goat mobile the goat
mobile will
about the farm with the goats and the
goats will go up inside of it I'll feed
them inside of it so when I get ready to
move them I can just close the door and
move the goats and I also want to rig up
an apparatus probably on the front here
that keeps the hay bale up off the
ground where the goats have to reach up
and eat that's going to make for some
fun times on the Stoney Ridge farmer
channel building this thing we'll call
it the goat mobile you know I went
searching farm channels and looking for
ways to feed goats that you know they
didn't waste so much hay and there's
just not a lot of information out there
so I'm gonna put some info out there for
you guys I hurt my finger the other day
out this finger right here not my middle
finger but my ring finger on my right
hand I think I broke it on something the
other day kind of got twisted and it's
like you hear about the tiger that got a
thorn in his paw you just can't function
I just I'm having the hardest time
because I just want to work I want to be
able to throw stuff and pick stuff up
and this hand is really hindering that
it's a bummer as you can see it's a pain
in the butt hopefully having the goat
mobile and a place to keep the hay up
off the ground will solve this problem I
won't have to get in here and do this
anymore all right we got our chores done
with the goats we ride down here to the
shop at this unboxing done and get the
wheels off of this lawnmower at least
the plan is today to get the front
wheels off I think I'm gonna take the
back tires off and take them to the tire
shop a local tire shop here does a
pretty good work in and they don't
charge very much so we'll take the tires
to the tire shop
have them go through make sure they
don't have any leaks and if they do
we'll have them put patches in the
inside of the tire and do it right that
way I'm not filling up tires all summer
long that's a pain in the butt I don't
know if you guys have ever experienced
that if you've ever experienced that
post me a comment guys I asked you click
that like button right now go down there
click that like button tell me what
you're thinking all right
so we've been putting off this job
pretty much all winter long
I bought the inner-tubes last fall
because I was just so sick of filling up
the tires on the lawnmower and I'll show
you over here they're probably already
flat again I just filled them up
yesterday yeah you can see that one
there it's going flat
and this one here is just it's just mush
first thing we got to do is sweep up
this area so we got a nice clean place
to work nobody wants to work in a big
pile of dirt
shop owners best friend right there so
much easier to sweep up your mess one of
these little handheld jobs like that
so one bad thing about a zero-turn the
large zero turn like this this is a
commercial john deere 777 you really
can't move it unless you start it so I
really hate to start an engine like this
and let it run for fifteen seconds and
back up it just seems to me it's doing
more harm than good but we got to get it
into the middle of the shop so we can
work on it
but the nice thing about having a zero
return is you can whip it around in a
little bitty tight spot
let me show you what we've got to do the
front tires on the zero turn come off a
little bit different than you know then
your normal tire let me show you
so what I'll have to do is jack it up
from this point right here and slip a
jack stand in right here and we
basically unbolt this bolt and the wheel
should come right off and you can see
that tyre is pretty much shot this one
this one holds air pretty good you know
the wheels are all kind of scrubby there
so we may do a little wheel restoration
we'll also just take this nut off and
remove it and we'll put jack stands
underneath here well fix these first and
then we'll take off the rears so the
rears have a pretty easy system you just
unbolt those four bolts and off comes
the wheel and I also write down 18 psi
so this is my piece of equipment it's
gonna be my piece of equipment until it
falls down dying and screaming it's
gonna go down in flames before I get rid
of it on my wheels I wrote down what the
PSI needs to be for the tires that way
I'm running the same tire pressure on
all four tires and I get a good even cut
so if you're really OCD like me
sometimes having a tire that's a
different pressure on one side a
lawnmower versus the other will cause
your cut to be off you know it'll cause
you to get an uneven cut on your lawn
and make your lawn look like crap we
want our lawn to look like gold so
that's why I'm so obsessed with tire
pressure and getting these tires right
because I check the tire pressure before
I mow every time I always check the oil
and I always check the tire pressure
that way I don't make a mess what good
what all this work do if you went out
and mowed your yard and it looked like
crap when you got done so we're gonna
use these little wimpy jack stands we'll
take our jack get our mower up off the
ground here slide in our jack stands
we need to do a little manual
manipulation here there we go
pop that dude loose that suckers in
there I'm gonna have to get him a rubber
hammer and tap on it a little bit always
be careful if you're hammering on some
bolts or something like that that you
don't damage the threads if you're gonna
hammer on them so we're gonna get the
rubber deadblow hammer to knock this
thing out with deadblow every guy needs
a dead blow hammer in his toolbox I'll
post links to all the tools that I'm
using down below in the video
description if you see something in here
that you're thinking about getting
there'll be a link down below if you
think you need it it's down there man
pain in the butt put the wrench on it
come on out of there buddy nothing's
ever easy
I will now deploy the beater screwdriver
everybody needs a good beater
screwdriver nothing ever goes like it
should so this thing should have just
slid right out it's rusty it's been
outsides head grass on it grass is
really acidic and grass is really really
hard on metal so when I get done with my
mower I normally try to blow it off the
best I can I'll take the leaf blower and
blow it off and then once every couple
weeks I'll take the air hose and blow it
off try to get all that old grass off
there especially wet grass don't use a
water hose just blow it off Buster out
of here come on Buster come on out of
there good lord you're making me look
bad I'm gonna knock it back and forth a
couple times see if that makes it slide
out a little easier of course it doesn't
good gracious I'm gonna have to use the
feet
there we go that's what daddy likes
there we go
see all that crusty rustiness we'll
clean that up before we put it back on
all right so here's our wheel entire
assembly has two little grease caps on
the ends right here that one and that
one and those cover up the bearings
we'll set those to the side and we'll
look at our bearings our wheel bearings
in here and make sure they're turning
free you can tell here this one really
isn't turning that free this one yeah
they're both kind of gummed up my
inclination is to clean them up really
good take the air hose and clean them up
really good maybe put a little bit of
oil in there what I did not know is
there is a metal shim down in there
about that long like a tube down inside
this wheel so I'm gonna slide the bolt
back in here that's what it was all
hanging up on there so that's kind of
kind of work it back and forth here
trying to work that rest off anytime
you're doing a job like this you might
as well try to do it right make sure
everything's functioning properly when
you put it back together I'm gonna rub
and clean on these bearings a little bit
and put some white lithium grease on it
I think that's probably the right thing
to do if you guys are wondering the free
lawn mower that I got still on the back
of the hundred dollar truck we'll get
that off in the next day or so it's
supposed to be a rainy day coming up I
want to get it off there bring it in the
shop here on a rainy day and take the
engine off of it first we got to make
sure it fires up so we'll throw a
battery on it and see if it fires up
there we go spinning pretty freely
they're not brand new and we don't
expect them to be brand new but they're
not making any kind of grinding noises
or anything so I'm okay with that
let me start by saying I've never done
this here's the inner tube the new tube
and appears to tire this is a tubeless
tire that's in it right now and I'm
really wondering how the valve stem
situation is gonna work out so we're
gonna go on and open our tube hopefully
this isn't beyond my scope of practice
okay cool so it has a metal valve stem
on the two
and this is a Carlile lawn and garden
trailer - but I think it's what it says
yeah lawn and garden trailer tube cool
and the tire is a 13 by 6.5 once again
I'm not done this before I have a tire
removal tool basically for a mountain
bike and I'm gonna try to get in here
and wedge the tool in and ring it around
and pull that tool that tire back to the
side and then I'll slide the tube in and
put the valve stem through hopefully
that'll be good I think the first step
in this should be removing the valve
stem good lord
right now some of your Pro tire guys are
laughing at me I probably need to cut
this don't I yep so we'll give it a
little bit of a slice here razor knife
that suckers tough it's got metal in it
so basically you have to I'll show
you here you basically have to take your
valve stem and it over like that
and then cut right in there and that's
what I'm gonna do right here and that'll
get that valve stem to where I can
remove it man having this messed up
finger makes everything a pain in the
butt every time I bump it on something
it hurts cuz I'm a big wuss and that's
how I roll good lord that's some good
rubber on there yeah there it is that's
what it looks like we'll get rid of that
throw him in the trash can over here
inside the tire is now the little valve
stem okay so we know when we pop our
tire off with our tire tool which
hopefully works we know that we've got
to get that valve stem a little rubber
piece out of there or that's going to be
a potential hazard we're going to take
the tire off the rim on the valve stem
side about me a tire changing tool to
get it off
ladies and gentlemen huh this is beyond
what I can do in this shop I'm just
going to pull off four wheels
this is beyond what I can do I'm gonna
pull all four wheels make sure all the
bearings are okay all the bearings are
good but uh this is beyond what I can do
I'm gonna have to take it to the tire
shop that that thing right there is
really it has a huge lip on it and it's
a really really stout tire you know this
is a commercial mower so it may be best
that I have them put air in the tire and
fix up the rim I'd like to take the
wheel all the way off scrape it clean
with a wire brush or a wire wheel and
make sure it seats really well the
problem with this is that the wheel is
rusting right in here and it's rusting
along the edge where the tire touches it
now once again my farm tractor tire
store knows how to deal with this stuff
and they'll hit it with a wire wheel and
be done they'll probably hit it with a
little bit of primer too it's a job for
another day that's a bummer you know
sometimes that works out that way well
let's get over here
and we'll set this tire and wheel down
we'll go ahead and pop off all the
wheels and tires and I'll get them all
cleaned up and ready to take to the tire
store make sure not only have any leaks
and that they'll hold air okay let's get
over here to the unboxing I want to show
you all the cool stuff that I got
basically I just bought a box of goodies
that I need around the farm I bought my
favorite kind of overalls I bought two
different kinds of mounts to put on the
Gator and we'll try both of those mounts
they're like a hook type mount I'll show
you in a second and and we'll tell you
which one's the best so I think that's
what it's all about is learning what's
the best what works and what doesn't
work
so let's show you what we got my little
friend came to help me
you my friend shake my hand good girl
good girl
here's what we got this is a huge box
from Amazon
we bought double rhino clips for the
Gator and we'll put those on either in
the next vlog or in Monday or Tuesday
blog we'll put these on it's a clip
designed to hold two rifles or two
shovels or two
whatever I really want to start keeping
a rifle like kind of a beater rifle 22
or something on the Gator so in case we
run across a coyote we can take care of
business and the next thing is these
Copland mounts these are ratcheting
Rhino grips and we'll install these we
already have one of these on the Gator I
have been through five of these they
work really great until you bump into a
tree and they don't hold up so good
bumped into a tree heavy-duty magnets so
I have a steel building if you guys have
a steel building this that's what this
is is a steel building a steel structure
and in this box right here I bought two
boxes of them there are 40 pound magnets
I'll post links to all this stuff down
below and especially once we start
putting this stuff together I'll post
links on that these are heavy-duty
magnet hooks and they're really
heavy-duty because it's hard for me to
get them apart so basically they come
gosh almighty
things on there nothing's going right
alright so this is the little magnet and
it's a 40-pound magnet and it screws in
to a little hook like that and I use
these all over the place here in the
shop so you can screw it in screws in
nice and tight
and you stick it on your metal building
so let me show you so I've got several
types of these this is a really really
heavy duty one I've got some locks
hanging in here this is one and I have a
gate opener on it and basically they
just stick on there like good gracious
let's do a comparison so I bought this
one on Amazon and I got this one at
Walmart I can whack that I can white
coat that one that one just falls off so
this is extremely stout and if you
wanted to you could probably put a
longer bolt in there so if you've got a
steel building like this these hooks are
indispensable you need to hang stuff up
hang your keys up or whatever these
Walmart brand or whatever brand these
are these little cheapies are not so
good so tried-and-true it's almost this
stout is that one right there so I'll
post a link down below
gosh that thing's on there
they stick really really good they'll
hang 40 pounds a little tiny magnet this
thing's as big as a nickel and then a
whole 40 pounds it's amazing so the last
thing that we ordered the last few
things that we ordered is what we're
gonna be wearing throughout the summer
while we work on the farm and that is
overalls so these are the key brand
overall and the style pocket that these
have in them there's a snap pocket and
another snap pocket and a place for your
pin and then I have the Liberty brand
I'll show you the difference in the
Liberty brand pocket and the key brand
guys if you've never worn a set of
bibbed overalls you might think you look
like an idiot
you might feel like an idiot for the
first day or the first 15 minutes that
you wear them once you wear these things
around your farm and around your house
you'll realize how restrictive your belt
is on your belly
it basically constricts you in the
midsection of your body and makes you
have a gut they're really really
lightweight so if we get tired of me in
long pants we'll cut them off and make
some really sexy shorts and this is the
Liberty brand and the Liberty brand it
has a different feel to it it's more of
a I would say more of a country looking
brand and it has a bigger front pocket a
bigger front in it has a zipper pocket
here which is very very convenient whoop
you put your phone in there and your
phone won't get all dirty and dusty
which is very nice and you can feel it
vibrate on your chest and it also has
the snap pocket with one big pocket in
there and it also has a spot for your
pin it's kind of a toss-up between the
Liberty and the key I'll tell you what I
think at the end of the summer or
sometime later on whether I like the key
or the Liberty better or what I have on
right here which is a Carhartt the only
problem with the Carhartt that I have is
this right here this is turning into a
clothing commercial it's not what I
wanted to do but what I want to tell you
about things that are good and things
that are bad and the problems that I run
into so that maybe you can use those
things and learn from me and not make
those mistakes just like trying to take
that tire off the issue I've had with a
Carhartt brand is this little tab right
here this little tab it likes to get
hung up in the washing machine and you
can see
that's frayed to the very end the
overalls are only as good as the clips
will last this one got hung up too and
it's all bent out of shape you can see
it's bent right there take it for what
you will I do like the Carhartt brand
it's very robust it's very tough twits
my winter time overall however these
dude like to get hung up in the washing
machine and get twisted so yeah take
that for what it is well guys that's
kind of it for the vlog today thanks a
lot for watching please click that like
button click that thumbs up don't forget
there's going to be a lot of good stuff
to come we're gonna build a goat mobile
we've got to put all those little
attachments there's a little grippy
attachments on the Gator and I'll show
you how they fit and how rifles and
stuff fit in there and how shovels and
stuff fit in there if it's something you
might want for your UTV and we got to
get these tires off get them to the tire
store and take care of business so I
don't want to fool with flat tires and
put air and tires and carrying around a
compressor and carrying around an air
tank all summer long we're gonna solve
this problem tomorrow's plan is me and
mrs. Stoney Ridge are gonna move the
goats or at least build the fence to
move the goats to a new section of
pasture and after we move them at some
point once it dries out we're going to
set that field on fire burn all that
broom straw and let those nutrients soak
into the soil which will make the grass
pop it'll just make it green and
beautiful thanks a lot guys click the
like button we'll see you next time if
you're not already subscribed subscribe
to the channel click the little bell
down there and I'll notify you when I
post a new video all right talk to you
soon
[Music]
Pierce we've had some ways opposed to me
stone Tyrion
[Music]
look at in there